it's one of my favorite holidays and
it's just
around the corner i love costumes and
candy
and all the frightening delicious foods
we can make
here with a scary good recipe to get you
into the halloween spirit
is the host and judge of halloween
baking championship
miss hooty who herself hi again to carla
hall
hey okay yes
jumpsuit yes i wear it like every time
i'm in the kitchen i don't know why i
have the idea and then of course it has
my i love food yes
i love food too i feel like i should
have a sign on i love food
i will make you one stop it make you
like a sandwich board i would want to
like i
sometimes i lose my voice from the show
and i love it because i just have like a
little
post-it stuck to me and it's like voice
rest i'm like
can't talk um so we'll we'll just
we'll we'll get a post-it for today but
we'll make you a professional sign
all right season six of the show how is
it different may i ask i mean the
biggest difference is
i am a judge and a host and
it was filmed during covet like post
covet so
the you will see that everybody spread
out but it is
amazing and i feel like as the host
i get to get in there and see the
baker's baking
so but i'm still impartial but
it is so nice to actually see their
process yeah
well baking is such a you know i bake
with my kids all the time
and so i'm really excited to learn this
recipe because we
also really love making eggs eggs pastas
baking stuff like that's sort of our jam
in the kitchen so
teach me how to make these
okay all right so
um boiling eggs you put your coal
your eggs in the water yup you bring it
up to the boil
you once it starts to boil you put a top
on and that's when the timer starts
okay these are cooked for three minutes
you take them out you cool them
really yeah with a soft yolk so this is
a shortcut deviled egg
oh i love that because you know i love
an egg salad i love a doubled egg but a
time is a factor
a time is for for egg salad six minutes
really so i crack my egg and then i'm
changing my life right now carl
oh i want to change your life yeah
that's right
so how are you peeling eggs um i went
like with a little
crack crack crack crack crack crack i do
it in the water the water helps because
i
dunk and i peel i don't right
i'm just gonna say this went a lot more
sensual
oh it does feel okay silky yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um oh my god this is so exciting
i feel like now i can make deviled eggs
like more not just
a special occasion but wait for your egg
salad don't cook them all the way
so if you go with the six minute egg and
it's still soft and you tear the egg and
then you
you fold it into the mayonnaise it makes
it creamy
yeah exactly that's what i was just
going to say it must make it a lot
creamier
yep okay what do we do once we peel the
egg all right so we're going to we're
going to make our sauce so we have our
mayo
yep and then we're going to put in some
mustard we have some yellow mustard
i love mayonnaise and mustard so much
right already in love with this sauce
because of the tanginess because of the
vinegar and then we're going to add
cayenne and paprika because we want to
make the sauce orange
am i doing all the paprika yep this
oh right because i was gonna say i got
so excited about um the color
aspect and my daughter loves food
coloring
and she plays with it all the time in
the kitchen and
i'm not gonna lie it's not the easiest
thing to clean up
okay can i tell you like yesterday i was
like oh we're gonna dye these eggs we're
gonna use turmeric
everything's yellow we're not doing that
yeah
i mean my fingernails and so i abandoned
that because i know your color's yellow
but i didn't want to have yellow all
over me
no i i get it i my i'm a stain removal
enthusiast like nobody's business
and my daughter gives me the biggest run
for my money every day of my life
all right so you've got that yes are you
orange yes i'm orange
do you want to taste it
i went right in it was like i was
literally like uh like oh all right yeah
so oh my god
carla this almost tastes like a deviled
egg in itself
i'm not kidding it's giving me deviled
egg taste
exactly oh my god i get it
okay changing your life one egg at a
time i'm having such a revelation
right so feel this egg you see how soft
it is feel it
boom you feel it yeah yeah yeah
again another very sensual experience
exactly so we're going to cut that in
half lengthwise
and look god
oh it's perfect
i love when an egg turns out
right i wanted to make out with
something i mean look at this where's my
camera
i mean look at that look at the oh my
gosh yes
oh
right hello oh i'm spilling but okay
i know because it's like oozing out okay
now so here is the quick
shortcut part all right take another
spoon you're gonna take
this mayo and put it on the egg you're
not
dipping you're not taking anything out
of that egg because that yolk belongs in
that egg you're just going to add
something on top of it
a black olive to make a little eye let's
do it
what then because you need blood
i mean well hey baby
whatever happens in the kitchen stays in
the kitchen oh my god sriracha
i love sriracha these are our veins
these are our little
egg little veins blood vessels
let's do a beauty shot carlos okay let's
do it these are
so yeah okay i'm doing right here like a
beauty shot
[Applause]
what franco carla
go to the drewberry marshall.com for the
full recipe
this one works for the whole family and
tune in to halloween baking championship
on the food network
[Music]
you